let's talk about the president's future
opponents it's a long line of Democratic
candidates we've possibly got Joe Biden
throwing his hat into the ring maybe
better or or Caswell Bernie Sanders back
in the mix who do you think represents
his toughest challenger honestly I am
not worried about anybody that has
gotten into there to the no and I'll
tell you because I really do believe
that Donald Trump is gonna win by more
in 2020 than he did in 2016 I think the
reality is it would be so stupid for
people to spend their money to waste
their money and time and effort right
now to try and run against him I
actually don't understand why there are
so many people that are have gotten in
the race on the Democrat side I almost
wanted to tell them wait until 2024 wait
till he's out you're not gonna beat
Donald Trump nothing will ever be quite
like 2016 I mean that was such a unique
sort of grassroots campaign you know
none of us had any experience in
politics none of us I don't want to say
none of us really knew what we were
doing but nobody gave us a guidebook to
say here's how you how you do this we
sort of figured it out as we went so
certainly there will be changes I mean
already at the campaign we're light
years ahead now of where we were at the
same place for the campaign in 2016 how
pivotal do you think women voters could
be do you think they could decide 2020
well women are half of our population
for sure I mean women are here we are
two women together you you know as well
as I do women are our huge force in this
country and we we actually represent
over half the vote in this country so it
will be a huge component I think what
people often miss when it comes to this
president
people always say Donald Trump has a
problem with women I don't think that's
the case I can't tell you the number of
women that come up to me on a daily
basis even here in New York and are so
excited about our president and are so
thankful that that he he decided to run
and that he's doing the things that he
said he was going to do and the reality
is people are made to feel like they
can't talk about it especially women I
think they're not talking to their
friends about it they're not posting on
social media they're really not going to
talk to a pollster and
give them an honest answer about
supporting Donald Trump you talk about
the president's success with women do
you think moments like the Brett
Cavanaugh confirmation hearing and those
allegations against him actually helped
galvanize Donald Trump's support base
rather than turn them against him yeah
absolutely without a doubt the reality
is in this country and I think as every
single day goes by it's become more
apparent to people the media and the
Democrats are obviously have teamed up
in some capacity and are doing anything
and everything they can to go against
this president and I think you look at
things like Brett Kavanaugh he was
treated so horribly this is an
incredible man with an incredible
background who deserved almost more than
anyone to be a Supreme Court justice and
yet you see the allegations alleged
against him and these were again just
allegations there was no real evidence
there was nothing to back it up and yet
it seemed as though as you're saying
there was a groundswell of women that
were coming out against the president
against Brett Kavanaugh when that really
wasn't the case that was how the media
portrayed it what do you think your
father-in-law of uses his greatest
success and if if you'll entertain it
his greatest failure so far in office I
mean I think he would say maybe his his
most disappointing thing that's happened
has been the personnel you know there
are so many people that you think are
loyal to this country and support you
and have your back and then you you turn
around and and you see what's happened
with Michael Cohen with people like
Omarosa with so many of these people who
were clearly out for themselves and and
really looking to make a quick buck
Michael Cohen is a self-admitted
perjurer and liar he's obviously trying
his his last-ditch effort to reduce his
time in prison sadly for him he perjured
himself several more times in front of
Congress the last time he testified I
don't worry about that at all I mean it
doesn't take you 15 years to figure out
somebody's a racist unless they're not a
racist and and Michael Cohen was part of
the Trump Organization and worked with
the president
fifteen years and now all of a sudden he
decided he's a racist and you know why
it's because it's a convenient thing for
him to say he thinks it's gonna lessen
his prison time and you know what he's
probably also looking for a book deal
down the line recently Paul Manafort was
sentenced to 47 months in prison for
various financial crimes and the
recommended sentence was between 19 and
24 years and there was some shock at how
small some viewed that sentence to be
what's your view do you think it was
fair well first let's talk about the
fact that Paul Manafort is going to
prison for nothing that has to do with
Donald Trump it always comes up and
people are interested in Paul Manafort
because he worked for the Trump campaign
for a couple of months as the campaign
manager unfortunately for him in his
previous business dealings he did things
illegally he did things the improper way
that's why he's going to prison but yet
it always gets lumped in with President
Trump imagine that I listen I don't know
why the judge decided to rule the way he
did I'm watching things as an American
citizen like everyone else I can tell
you that I think what has happened to
Paul Manafort as a result of his
participation in the Trump campaign and
as any association with this president
is that people have gone after him in a
way that they probably wouldn't go after
someone else and so perhaps the judge
saw that for what it is and saw what has
been done to to a man now yes he did
break the law so he deserves to go to
prison he deserves what he's getting the
rushar investigation has proved a real
frustration to the president and the
administration are you concerned that
there might be more charges further down
the line and and possibly more
distractions from what the president is
trying to do well I'll tell you I find
the Russia investigation to be the
biggest waste of time and taxpayer money
that has possibly ever happened in this
country there's lots of discussion I
think because of the business background
of the family the size of the family and
that you're all very visible on the
campaign trail do you think there should
be any limits to the influence that
family members can have in the White
House
I think if you have someone like Jared
and Ivanka who are incredibly smart
people who are doing things that are
very supportive of this president and
the agenda that he has for the country
there they're not doing things for
themselves they're doing things for him
I don't think that there's there should
be any issue with having a family member
there in fact sometimes a family member
is the only person you know you can
really trust the first lady has come
under some criticism there was a lot of
controversy when she wore the jacket
that said I really don't care in the
middle of the caravan crisis and she's
been quite critical of press coverage do
you think she feels victimized I think
that would be a stretch to say Melania
feels victimized she's an incredibly
strong woman she's an incredibly smart
woman she might be smarter than all of
us because she actually stays out of the
media spotlight as much as she possibly
can I don't think she feels victimized
they think she feels frustrated like the
rest of us you know no matter what you
do no matter what you wear is there
anything about the president that might
surprise us you know him extremely well
you've seen things that the rest of us
haven't they're at I mean you've seen
him vulnerable or emotional perhaps even
dare I say cry well I've never seen him
cry but listen he gets this reputation
as this big bold brash guy and he
certainly is that at the right times but
when he's with family he loves being
with family he's just like anybody else
he wants to be surrounded by the people
he loves we don't get to see him enough
you know so when we're all together for
holidays or occasionally get together
for a meal I mean we just laugh he's one
of the funniest people I've ever met
he can tell a story and a joke unlike
anybody else truly loves his grandkids
so much all he wants to do whenever I
see him the first thing is he asked me
about my son Luke let me see some
pictures do you have any videos of him
and I try to send as much of as I can
you know I'll send some stuff to the
White House if I can I never know if or
when when he gets it but but he's got
such a great heart
you know you
you don't hear enough about the things
that he's done for people especially in
the past when nobody was looking before
Donald Trump became Donald Trump there's
stories about him pulling over on the
side of the road in New Jersey to help
somebody who had broken down giving
people rides places when they didn't
need to paying off a mortgage on
somebody's house that worked for him
because he heard that they were
struggling financially these are all
things that Donald Trump has done in the
past that's truly his heart he would
give his shirt off his back for anyone
and I think he gets so mislabeled by the
media as being a person that doesn't
care as not having a kind heart he
really cares about people in this
country he cares about America that's
why he's doing this job that's why he's
taking the heat he takes every single
day unnecessarily but but I just wish
more people knew that side of him the
the incredible kind things that he's
done throughout his life looking for no
recognition whatsoever and and he
continues to do it but for the American
people